the next category is special effects my  award for the finest achievement and  special effects would go to Gina  Lollobrigida however the official  academy award will be presented by that  fine actor lee jiae call  the special-effects gentlemen are those  wizards of optical illusion who can  produce a tornado an earthquake for the  end of the world all on a quiet  afternoon in Burbank mr. melih the  winner is 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea  ladies and gentlemen Walt Disney  received the award from Walt Disney  Studios this is a group effort this is a  group effort effort the many men play a  part in doing creating these effects and  it is for them that I accept this award  thank you I wanted why drove up in that  truck